here's why you shouldn't freak out about
olaplex making you infertile in the
report they take the worst case scenario
and assume that you're using lilial in
15 different beauty products every day
even with using this many products
you're only getting 1 80th of the
smallest dose estimated to cause a
negative health effect in rats the most
sensitive of the animal studied they
also looked at data from mice and dogs
they are being really cautious here hair
products also contribute very little to
this they estimate that you probably get
about 70 times as much lilial from
applying perfume from hair products
you're getting about one ten thousandth
of the smallest amount that would give a
negative health effect so this is very
much a precautionary band the eu treats
things that could cause reproductive
issues very seriously i think this man
is a good thing lilial is used as a
fragrance ingredient so olaplex will
still work without it companies have
known about the band coming in for a
while so they've been phasing it out but
it is incredibly unlikely that using
olaplex has made you infertile